There's a genre of sci-fi
that gives us a glimpse into the future
that's totally different.
In fact,
the polar opposite of the dystopia
that we see in Cyberpunk,
and it's called SolarPunk.
It's idyllic,
it's sustainable, it's communal,
and it's
a yogurt ad.
In fact, unlike Cyberpunk,
there's not a whole lot of examples
of good solar punk in mass media.
And the best visual examples
seem to be kind of missing the point.
When we analyzed solar punk
from an architectural and urban planning
point of view, we found out just how many
parallels there were to our reality.
So solar punk, could this be our future?
A portion of this video sponsored by HP
and Intel.
This video
is probably one of the best depictions
of solar punk.
It's a future where we merge
fusion technology with eco centric values
and we thrive in harmony with nature.
But the more we learned
about the movement, we realize
the existence of this video is
actually the antithesis of solar punk.
The punk in both solar and cyberpunk
refers to rebellion.
Cyberpunk is against an oppressive techno
dystopia,
and solar punk is against consumerism
and capitalism, which is leading
to the destruction of the planet.
The solar is both literal
and metaphorical.
Literally, it represents solar
and other renewable energies.
And metaphorically
it's talking about this beacon of light
in a dark cyberpunk world
run by corporate interests.
So an ad
using these beautiful solar punk esthetics
and using this utopian vision
to convince people to buy their products
seems very anti-social or punk.
And unlike cyberpunk,
which is a huge part of pop culture,
the real solar punk
seems to only exist in classify
novels or in a really small
niche section of the Internet.
There are films and video games out there
that fit the solar punk esthetic,
but they don't quite fit
the true definition of solar punk
when it comes to the social
or cultural aspects socially.
It emphasizes unity,
a shared responsibility
and harmony
between both nature and fellow humans.
And the combination of these words
kind of immediately
make you think of a cult.
And why is it
maybe it's Hollywood
who's done a really good job of
glamorizing this idea of the sexy, rugged
rebel with a six pack on a motorbike
navigating this dark dystopian world?
I mean, there is nothing really sexy
about Ryan Gosling in a far market.
Okay, that's still pretty hot.
Let's look at Wakanda from Black Panther.
It's probably one of the few iconic
solar powered visions from Hollywood.
It's the most technologically advanced
country in the world.
But instead of a city like this, it's
surrounded by sweeping valleys
and mountains.
Technically,
Wakanda doesn't qualify as solar power
because it's a matriarchal society
and it's not really culturally diverse.
But there is a beautiful integration
of technology into the city's fabric,
and at the same time,
the entire society is grounded
in traditions
that's passed down for generations.
But I think the most solar punk elements
Wakanda actually came
from the location of the Golden City
and this abrupt transition
between the city
and the surrounding landscape.
If you look at any North American city,
the periphery is surrounded
by highways and suburbs.
Something like 52% of Americans
live in suburbs.
Suburbs emerged partly
because cities were polluted and dangerous
and weren't really nice to live in.
So in the fifties and sixties, as soon as
we had the sudden boom in car ownership,
people realized, Hey,
I could live in bigger houses
with green space for less money
if I just moved out of the city.
But studies show that suburban dwellers
emit up to four times
the amount of emission
the people living in urban areas
because you're dependent on cars,
there's longer commutes
and you're sharing less
and less resources.
And the creation of a new suburb
often consumes
natural habitats and agricultural lands.
Suburbs also lead to segregated
neighborhoods with very little cultural
or social diversity, which can contribute
to a bigger socioeconomic divide.
Rather than trying to address
the problems in the city.
We simply moved our population
to the outskirts.
And to this day, in many parts of North
America, the suburbs keep growing.
It's ironic because the idea of a tight
knit community living in open space
with greenery, there is a lot of parallels
to solar Park ideals.
In fact,
both the design of suburbs and solar punk
were inspired
by the same idea The Garden City movement.
If you want to talk about
real polluted and dirty cities,
we have to look at London, England.
During the late 19th century,
industrialization completely transformed
London into one of the most slum,
disgusting, unhealthy places to live in.
Sanitation was virtually non-existent,
and the factories,
they just dumped everything
into the river,
which is also
where they got their drinking water
because the industrial revolution
was completely unprecedented
and cities just weren't equipped to handle
the kind of influx of people
and factories.
This is when Ebenezer Howard,
an urban planner
from London, came up
with this utopian concept for cities
living in nature
and called them Garden Cities of Tomorrow.
A group of slum less smokeless
cities, each city
or community would have a central district
that was dedicated to industry and work.
From there
you have concentric rings of housing,
gardens, agriculture,
leisure space and civic institutions.
These circles
were just posed to be diagrammatic.
But I think what's interesting
is that these circular green belts
were a boundary and you could limit
the growth of the population by design.
And when you limit growth,
you can also control the density, the cost
and the quality of life.
He even suggested roughly sizes.
Each city would be roughly 6000 acres,
with anywhere
between 32000 to 58000 people
and the city ring
would occupy one six of that space,
leaving the rest to green space.
These experimental garden cities started
to pop up all over America and the U.K.,
but very few actually became successful
because while
it had the look of a Garden city,
it lacked a lot of the other
characteristics like an industry, food
production, civic institutions, meaning
people would still need to take their cars
and drive to get to these places,
which in turn created suburbs.
But before we continue, a
message from our sponsor,
HP and Intel, I'm always on the go.
So the ideal laptop for me
is portable and lightweight.
A 14 inch laptop
can adapt to every situation
and I want as many options as possible
when it comes to sports.
Like a full size HDMI port and a usb-a.
But even if this laptop is tiny,
it doesn't mean
that you can't use rhino
and other apps at the same time.
The HP Elitebook 1040 can be equipped
with up to 64 gigabytes of RAM,
and this version has a 13 generation
intel processor with 14 cores
HP and Intel came together and developed
an exclusive feature called HP Smartsense,
which provides scalable performance
that allows high processing power
with an A design that stays light.
Cool and quiet.
The HP Presence app offers a really great
feature for virtual conferencing,
like connecting multiple cameras
at the same time.
In this case, I'm using my second camera
to frame the top of my desk,
and the Keystone
feature automatically reframes the view
based on the size of your document.
With Auto Camera Select, I recognizes
the camera that I'm looking at,
so I never have to break my contact.
There's lots of other features
that I really like about this laptop,
like the physical camera,
shutter fingerprint scanner,
and really great speakers.
So if you want to know more about the HP
Elitebook 1040, check the link
in the description, but maybe
we need to look outside of North America.
This is Almir in Flevoland Netherlands,
which was also inspired
by the Garden City movement
and according to an article in Blue
Labyrinth, could be considered
the very first real world solar punk city.
All mirror is only possible
thanks to modern engineering.
They literally brought a submerged
piece of land back from the sea.
The whole reason behind
creating all mirror is to prevent
the growing population of Amsterdam
and the Randstad area from expanding
into the designated green areas.
And like the Garden City diagram,
it's a number of semi separate nuclei,
each with its own neighborhoods,
facilities and identity
connected through a shared infrastructure
and a city center.
Different neighborhoods have distinct
identities, from colorful Regenboogbuurt
to the diverse Homeruskwartier
with over 1000 self-built homes.
The districts are separated
by water and parks and woodlands
or agricultural land
where they produce food.
And apparently Almir has over 100%
more green space
per inhabitant than any other Dutch city
of a similar size.
It's the newest city in the Netherlands,
and yet it's considered
the most successful new town.
It's only a few decades old,
but it's become Netherland's
eighth most populated city.
In a lot of ways.
Almir sounds like the perfect
implementation of Garden City
and solar punk ideals, but
when you look closely,
you start to notice
behind the sustainable facade.
It's also subject to the same
economic realities as any other city.
Because to build a successful city,
for it to scale from a village
to a city of thousands of people,
you need capital.
Capital for infrastructure
or for governments, for administration.
The locally grown food might not be enough
to sustain this larger
population, so maybe you have to transport
food from other places.
With a bigger population,
there's probably going to be more
waste and pollution, even if it's designed
with sustainable principles,
which again requires more money to manage.
So most cities are designed
and made possible within this capitalistic
framework zoning regulations
and even the layout of a city grid
allows us to expand more efficiently
compared to a more organic
mixed use layout, which is harder to plan.
And it's just hard to please everyone.
The scale is usually way beyond human
scale because in order to maximize profit,
you need to maximize the size
of your building,
often at the expense of green spaces
or community spaces.
Many public spaces
are actually privatized,
which can limit access to certain people.
Even actual public spaces like Times
Square
can be taken over by private interests
very quickly through marketing.
Even things like transportation
networks are designed to support
areas with high economic activity
or potential for growth.
And of course, the thing that drives
everything is land value.
So you have one party
whose only interest is driving up
the value of their properties.
But that's also where people live.
So there's kind of an inherent conflict
there.
Essentially, cities have very little to do
with the collective good
that solar pump talks about and a lot
to do with individual or corporate wealth.
And here we are
again, the foundations of cyberpunk.
So what if instead of trying to force fit
solar
punk into our existing idea of cities,
we start from the ground up.
This is our
the hewison again in the Netherlands.
It's a commune of 70 people
who organize themselves
into a social critique, meaning
they make decisions
through discussions and team consensus
rather than voting.
They also grow their own food,
they share responsibilities,
and they even build their own homes
using mostly recycled, reused
and locally sourced building materials
like tires filled with rammed Earth,
70% of their electricity and 100% of
their heating is generated on site
and they minimize energy intake
with passive strategies.
So from a social
and organizational perspective,
the city is pretty solar punk.
And it's not like there's
a size requirement for solar punk.
And it could definitely be a low density
settlement like this article
is, and grew out of the Earthship movement
from the late 20th century.
The earliest community
was built in New Mexico,
and it spread to small pockets
of communities around the world.
And since they're built by
the local communities with local materials
and site specific strategies, there's
a pretty big diversity in the designs.
But that just might be the problem.
Okay, when you think cyberpunk, what's
the first thing that comes to your mind?
Brutalism has
always been a pretty polarizing
architectural style.
A lot of people
absolutely hate these concrete monsters,
but it turns out when you put them in
the context of a bleak dystopian future,
they actually have a certain
kind of allure, so much
so that they become kind
of emblematic of cyberpunk.
And this lack of a common
architectural language.
And solar punk might seem trivial,
but architecture can often serve
as the glue that binds social movements
or a cultural ethos.
Whereas Mies van der Rohe said, it is the
will of an epoch translated into space.
For example, the powerhouse movement
was born as a response to World War One.
It symbolized
a vision of a new modern Europe.
It emphasized
functionality and simplicity,
and it said no to unnecessary ornaments.
It was so culturally transformative
that the principle extended
beyond architecture,
from art to furniture and textiles.
And I think it really brought people
together.
Solar punk right now
has a common esthetic,
but it's not really rooted in
anything solid that our culture can grasp.
So it's hard for us to imagine
it really existing in our reality.
In the last few
years, we've made some pretty big leaps
in energy
storage and electric transportation.
We have net zero buildings and also pretty
efficient systems for food production.
But if we are aiming for a true
solar punk society
and not the pretty solar punk renderings
that we see on Pinterest,
the society outlined by these die
hard solar punk fans.
Then there is a lot of economic,
structural,
social and architectural challenges
that we'd have to overcome.
But maybe it's just this kind of thinking.
That's the problem.
We've looked at a lot of cyberpunk
themes on this channel, and
I think it's tapping into this collective
pessimism that a lot of us share.
Okay.
I'm not saying that there aren't
a lot of indications
that we're headed towards
this dystopian future.
There are, but we are kind of conditioned
to expect the worst.
Neuroscientific research into defensive
pessimism
tells us that pessimism
can actually reduce anxiety,
especially when the outcome still
has the possibility to be prevented.
And this is partly because the brain
is predisposed to react more quickly
and readily to negative
stimuli compared to positive ones.
I think one of the reasons
cyberpunk wins out
is because being a pessimist is easier.
I remember taking this class
on sustainability in university
and just being completely
and totally depressed
because it just seemed like wherever
humans
go, ecological devastation
inevitably follows.
And this is the common rhetoric.
And as we get older, I think we start
to believe in this idea more and more.
We start believing
it's always been this way.
So it's probably going to be this way
in the future.
The thing that I like the most about solar
punk is the complete blatant rejection
of this idea that humans can exist
and thrive with nature and technology
and that a beautiful, glowing,
sustainable future is possible.
It's solution oriented
rather than dwelling on the problems.
It's the harder thing to do,
and maybe that's what makes it worth it.
Thanks for watching, guys.
Which team are you on?
Cyberpunk or solar punk?
Let me know in the comments below.
Also,
we have a newsletter and a Discord server.
We'll leave the links in the description.
And with that,
I'll see you guys in the next video.